[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos sobre los anticuerpos contra
el coronavirus que se podrían generar en
las personas que pasan por un contagio
lb y para tratar ese tema nos acompaña
el doctor carlos eduardo pérez médico
infectólogo de la universidad nacional
de colombia y asesor científico de
france 24 un estudio reciente de la
revista 'nature dice que quienes se han
contagiado de coronavirus son capaces de
generar anticuerpos de por vida doctor
que tanto se puede confiar en esta
información
juan y lo que es importante es que estos
anticuerpos y lo que dice la publicación
es que se podría generar una respuesta
anticuerpos en el tiempo a la familia de
los coronarios no específicamente el
sars co2 y esto es lo que abre es una
esperanza en el sentido de que la
vacunación podría durar un poco más de
tiempo lo que nosotros tenemos previsto
sin embargo esto es solamente una
evaluación in vitro todavía no podemos
decir de por vida de una infección que
solamente llega un pocos pocos años un
año un año y medio en la manía no
podemos predecir cómo se va a comportar
sin embargo la respuesta inmune si va a
perdurar más tiempo de lo que hace
usualmente en otros virus respiratoria
que implique exactamente la presencia de
anticuerpos en el organismo y cuál es el
aporte de las vacunas
una de las respuestas inmunológicas hay
dos tipos de respuestas inmunológicas
una de ellas es la que es mediada por
anticuerpos los anticuerpos son defensas
que son proteínas que neutralizan el
virus esta producción de anticuerpos la
hacen unas células que se llaman
linfocitos b y estos linfocitos b
reconocen esta infección y generan estos
anticuerpos incluso si ya no está
expuesto dejan de producirlos y cuando
en el tiempo se vuelve a exponer vuelven
a producir los anticuerpos los
anticuerpos neutralizan el antígeno que
es el virus que tan necesario es que una
persona que ya se haya contagiado reciba
varias dosis de la vacuna
muchas personas que han tenido infección
general ya la inmunidad generan los
anticuerpos sin embargo como esta
infección no es igual en todos hay
personas que tienen pocos síntomas o que
no producen una respuesta inmunológica
suficiente por eso es recomendable que
todas las personas que han tenido cobit
y que se hayan recuperado el presi ban
la inmunización para hacer como un
fenómeno de amplificación de la
respuesta inmunológica y que esta
respuesta inmunológica no dure meses
sino que podrá más del año como ésta
previéndose en los estudios clínicos que
se están desarrollando sobre ese tema
entonces más o menos cuánto tiempo se
estima que pueden durar entonces esos
anticuerpos en las personas después de
contagiarse de kobe 19
tenemos información científica que hasta
un año no es un año sino hasta un año
puede ser más tiempo la producción de
anticuerpos sea sostenida en las
personas que hayan tenido la enfermedad
o personas que han recibido la
inmunización con las vacunas que estamos
actualmente puede ser que con el pasar
del tiempo sepamos si se dura más tiempo
o cuándo será el mejor tiempo para re
vacunarse pero hasta ahora hasta un año
parece el tiempo más razonable que dure
este tipo de anticuerpos doctor de qué
depende entonces que una persona pueda
volver a contagiarse aún habiendo
desarrollado anticuerpos con un primer
contagio
los anticuerpos se producen para un
virus específico el problema que tenemos
ahora son los dirigen virales estos
linajes virales en la alfa y beta en el
gamma son linajes que parcialmente
pueden ser reconocidos por estos
anticuerpos entonces la reinfección no
depende de la producción de anticuerpos
sino en la circulación de linajes
algunos de ellos no lo reconoce el
sistema inmunológico y nos pueden volver
a infectar esa es la situación además de
los anticuerpos generados luego del
contagio de kobe 19 que otras formas de
defensa existen para combatir el virus
es importante también recordar los
anticuerpos es una parte pero de otra
que se llama inmunidad celular y hay
otra que se llama inmunidad de memoria
que son fundamentales para perpetuar la
respuesta inmunológica este tipo de
respuestas inmunológicas también se
estimulan con la vacuna y cada vez
tenemos más documentado de que le monial
celular y sobre todo una inmunidad de
las células de memoria van a ser capaces
de poder producir anticuerpos en el
tiempo contra el coronavirus y eso da la
esperanza de que la inmunidad va a durar
mucho más tiempo en los organismos y en
las personas que se vacunen por eso el
llamado es a vacunarse es algo seguro es
algo efectivo y que va a perdurar las
defensas en el tiempo de lector
muchísimas gracias como por si como
siempre usted es también gracias
quédense porque además mucho más
empresas 24 france24 puntocom
[Música]